hi bill this is Jason gots from big Fink
I'm reading a question that somebody
submitted in written form he wished to
remain anonymous but it seemed like a
question that it would be good to have
you answer I have a question about
homosexuality he asks if the purpose of
a species is to reproduce and survive
how would it make sense evolutionarily
for humans to have same sex preferences
are humans the only ones who practice
homosexuality and if so does this mean
that homosexuality is a product of
humans personal whim as opposed to
instinct so when I was growing up there
was this controversial and super
best-selling book called the naked ape
and this guy the author Desmond Morris
claimed I mean but I guess he documented
that there is homosexual behavior among
other problem primates in a way I
remembered I haven't read it in many
years with chimpanzees and bonobos to
exhibit homosexual behavior and the
answer nowadays that we give to
everybody about this is it's a spectrum
I don't know about you but I have known
a great many gay men who are married who
have babies who have kids
so I apparently I'm not an authority on
this I'm observer of the human condition
apparently there's a spectrum some
people are more inclined to have sex
with people of their same sex than
others and I think if you just watch the
news right now you can see that for
yourself
and so being somewhere on the spectrum
of heterosexual with homosexual being on
that is not genetically lethal you still
have kids anyway and you'll hear people
talk about the feminine side you'll hear
two people talk about the masculine side
you'll hear women use the expression
while she's got a lot of balls which I
can't literally be true if we're using
balls in that conventional construction
so I would say that it
something that happens in nature and I
remember very well in this book now I
haven't read it in a long time but man
it was a big deal
openly talking about sex in the 1960s
was a big deal that he claimed that
there was more homosexuality in zoos
than he observed in nature and that
maybe just because he had we happen to
capture a couple of homosexual bonobos
or whatever in other words the sample
size is way too small to extrapolate so
let's let's celebrate being alive
everybody apparently it's just something
that happens in nature and look we're
all here